where does the nobel prize fit into all
of this
you know if you think hundreds years
from now
i venture to say that people will not
remember the winners of a prize
but they'll remember creations like
these maybe i'm romanticizing
engineering
but i guess i want to ask how important
is the nobel prize in all this
um
well that's a it's a complicated
question it it uh
as a physicist it's something if you're
if you're trying to win a nobel prize
forget it because they give you know
one a year
so there's like there's been
200 physicists who've won the nobel
prize since 1900 and
and so that's
you know it's the and so things just
have to fall right so your goal cannot
be to win a world prize price wasn't my
dream
uh
it's uh
it's
uh tremendous for science i mean why the
nobel prize for a guy that made dynamite
and stuff is you know what it is it's a
long story but it's the one day a year
where actually the science that people
have done is all over the world and so
forth
forget about the people again you know
it is really good for for science
celebrating science it celebrates
science
for
you know several days different fields
uh you know chemistry
medicine and so forth
and uh
everybody doesn't understand everything
about these they're
generally fairly abstract but then it's
you know it's
on the front page of newspapers around
the world so it's really good for
science it's not easy to get science on
the front page of the new york times
it's not there
uh should be but it's not
and uh uh so the nobel prize is
important in that way uh
it's otherwise you know
i have a certain celebrity that i didn't
have before and
um
and now you get to be a celebrity that
advertises science it's a mechanism to
uh to remind us how incredible well
how much credit science deserves and
everything well it has a little bit more
one thing i didn't expect which is good
is that you know
we have a
government
i'm not picking on ours necessarily but
it's true of all governments are not run
by scientists in our case it's
run by uh
lawyers and businessmen yep okay
uh and at best they may have a an aide
or something that knows a little science
so
um so our country is
and all countries are hardly
um to hardly take into account
science
in
making decisions yes okay
and uh
having a nobel prize
the
people in those positions actually
listen
so
you have more influence i don't care
whether it's about global warming or
what the issue is there's some
influence which is lacking otherwise and
i
people pay attention to what i say if i
talk about global warming they wouldn't
have
uh before i had the nobel prize
uh yeah this is very true you're like
the celebrities who talk
celebrity has power uh celebrity has
power and that's that's that's a good
thing that's a good thing yeah uh
singling out people i mean on the other
side of it singling out people
has all kinds of you know whether it's
for an academy awards or for this
have unfairness and arbitrariness and so
forth and so on so
uh
you know that that's the other side of
the coin jessica said especially with
the huge experimental projects like this
you know it's a large team
and it does the nature of the nobel
prizes singles out a few individuals to
represent the team yeah
nevertheless is a beautiful thing
you